here at Northeast Derbyshire District
Council we're delighted to share with
you our four-year council plan
our vision is simple putting strong
Community leadership at the heart of
everything we do
we will create a great place for our
residents and visitors alike
did you know
Northeast Derbyshire is a largely rural
area set within one of the most
picturesque parts of the country
it's a business base with almost 5 000
businesses in our district
a great place to live well
a great place that cares for the
environment
a great place to access good Public
Services
a great place to work
you can find out more by reading our new
council plan online